my name is Lara tardy and I'm a
professor both in the genetics and the
radiation oncology departments at the
Stanford School of Medicine I grew up in
Southern California because my father
was a professor at Cal Tech so I'm a
little bit of an unusual case because my
two parents and stepparents were all
biologists I then went to Cornell
University for my undergraduate in
biochemistry did my PhD at University of
California at Berkeley with Robert Eagan
and then went to MIT where I decided I
wanted to study mouse models of cancer
with Tyler Jack's and after my postdoc
there I came out to Stanford for my
faculty position I really appreciate the
value of using a genetic model system
and I have been very committed to
studying cancer in the mouse and to
study this p53 tumor suppressor in that
setting and so we we try to do
experiments that will give mechanistic
insight into how p53 works
it's a transcription factor it activates
many target genes and we're working to
deconstruct the target genes that are
involved in its tumor suppressor
function I think it's just incredibly
satisfying and exciting to learn more
about how things work in biology and and
to do so in the context of a disease
that really it needs lots of attention
it's solving the cancer problem is a big
one and I am just thrilled to be part of
the effort that is trying to understand
how it develops and what we can do about
it by gaining that understanding